hello everyone we're here at epic
headquarters we have me Stacie community
manager Jim Brown Josh Marlow Chris
Branagh and we are here to show you some
official epic games concept art right
yeah I mean I don't know official isn't
really the right term it's a-workin so
Chris right we've kind of coined this
term working concept this is just me
basically kit bashing some things into a
level and playing with materials and
lighting and visual clarity theories and
things like that to try and come up with
a look that can kind of drive direction
across the project awesome we you also
have a map and I saw this this is um is
this Dave 'let's Polanski's map yeah
this is Dave's map what's it called CEO
for yeah steel for its in the test maps
folder and I just grabbed that and kind
of gave it this industrial vibe so we
were we Chris called me over the other
day and he said hey I wanted you to take
a look at something and I was I was
doing something else and I went over and
I looked nice when I thought wow this is
this is this looks really awesome and he
said what do you think and I said I
think I think you should go for it and
he printed out a copy of it so we will
have this picture available for you for
to use for your desktop or whatever you
want to do is for inspiration for what
you're doing in the game and Chris is
actually going to give you the first
look and we are going to take a fly
through the map maybe sure okay so let's
take a let's take a look at the the
picture I think we have a queued up
don't actually well we're in the map
right now okay so yeah okay
so I mean right now I mean unreal at
four and we're looking at kind of what
we're calling a working concept art
what I did was I kind of took some
theories of visual clarity and I started
to mesh this out with some of the things
that we had laying around in other
packages and from other projects and
stuff that's why it kind of looks a
little bit haphazard the wall columns
for example are made up of lots of
little pieces and things like that
but I think the overall look is clean it
will it will allow characters to pop off
the background this is not the look for
the entire game what I'm hoping to do is
the kind of the quality of this I'm
hoping to have to pick up through the
game where the lighting plays nice with
the materials and there's some color
patches here and there this in my mind
represents kind of the sci-fi industrial
look we could go grimy R with this but
when we talk about visual clarity and
things like that I think this kind of
thing hits that mark we've got some
details so it's not completely stark you
can see some areas that I haven't really
gone over yet some of the BSP stuff what
we're trying to do now is take a look at
where we're at how detailed we need to
go and what actually building
purpose-built message for some of these
columns and some of the doorways and
things we'll bring to the table right
this kind of defines a certain look
alien one Outland kind of mining base
type of look I don't know if the grime
is really showing up on on the stream
but you know it is pretty dirty it's
it's it's generally chalky and white and
kind of dirty and metallic and
reflective in some areas and stuff like
that but I think it's going to bring
what we're talking about as far as
visual clarity to the table right now
it's white it doesn't have to be we can
change the colors and I'm sure we're
gonna have multitude of colors the way I
approach this was I filled in medium
frequency detail big metal plating tubes
and pipes and some of the larger stuff
on top of that I started to lay in
high-frequency detail little fiddly fuse
boxes and antennas and pipes and things
like that those things give scale to the
environment and then on top of that we
started to layer in some color and some
decals and some lie
I think the overall impression is is
pretty cool and overall this is to me
unreal and and the entire franchise has
always been I used to use this term a
lot a Tim Burton Batman type of
caricature of itself right and where I'd
like to go with the new franchise is
more of a Chris Nolan kind of Batman
Begins it is Batman day you know just
something a little more polished a
little more realism but without going
over the top and and doing kind of like
what we did with with gears or ut3 and
making everything dark and grimy and
grungy I think you could still have
detailed environments that look amazing
and add color and have visual clarity
and have-your-cake- and-eat-it-too
basically you know I think this is this
to me is a really good example of of our
process that we use internally where we
start with a map that is just kind of
the basic the shell and we just focus on
the gameplay and then kind of
independent of us doing that a lot of
times Chris or hit the art guys will do
these little vignettes that are just
what would you call my little theme it's
it's busy it's vis dev right yeah you're
doing a visual prototype of an area or a
map that's it so these aren't
necessarily even made sometimes we don't
even you don't even use the maps that
were doing game play stuff in you're
just building how you think it should
look like you should feel and getting a
sense of scale and color and all that
stuff and right once we nail that stuff
down then we'll play it and we'll say
wow these columns are too thick or this
wall isn't flattened off or I'm getting
hung up on some of these meshes and
stuff like that
well yeah I know that some people are
looking at it right now I'm saying oh
boy I wonder if I'm going to get caught
on this so we haven't even gotten tested
this yet so we don't know yeah no this
is total vis dev right this isn't hey
I'm mr. Matt maker and I need all my
space and stuff right so this actually
is a very cramped map too so by building
out some of the mesh work it got even
more cramped and that's not okay we're
not gonna be able to do that right so
this is pure
visual hey here's a quality bar here's
what lighting should do there should be
lots of ambient occlusion that the
materials and the textures should be
light enough to allow for the lighting
to hit the darks and the lights that it
needs to create volume in the shapes the
color unifies things having multiple
crazy colors all over the places is cool
for some effects but not so much for
others and that's not kind of what we
were going for with this this might be
this could evolve into more of like a
lands remaining colony on an asteroid
right in the sky box turns into space
and there's a giant tractor beam in the
middle of the map flying up and into a
cracked asteroid mining or right and
magnetically or something down into the
facility and that gives it a sense of
place this is the first step this is hey
you know what what is the overall visual
identity of this visual clarity idea
that we have you know this is this is a
big step because this is what
everybody's been really asking is what
should I make my mouth look like which
where should I begin and this is a
really nice bright you know I hope it
inspires some people right I mean there
was a lot of questions about white
things and it being trendy and this and
the other thing and I I think this isn't
a clean reflective white that's been
flying around it's it's got some grime
it's got some wear to it for me it just
it feels really good with the lighting
and and we'll be playing around with
other things too we're obviously not
gonna be able to do a castle like this
or some of the other tech areas we
actually have some darker stuff that
recallers been playing around with that
looks fantastic as well and and the
castles yeah yeah so the answer to a lot
of those questions and I've read through
some of the ones we're gonna ask to that
is is UT is an evolving thing and and
it's it's an all-encompassing thing
there are many different environments in
UT and there's going to be different
colors and different environments but
what this does is it gives you may be a
quality bar hey all those different
things need to have a lighting quality
and a mood about them that feels like
this that gives you the feeling of this
it also gives our our art team a chance
to play around just like our
design team des where when you for is is
due to us as everyone else right so
we're playing with how does light
deflect off surfaces you know how do we
add details without overwhelming
polygons and ruining gameplay and all
this other stuff that we were just
talking about push process stuff and and
how it's it's so different from what
we've done in the past and sure so this
is our chance to I should say your
chance to play around in there and do
some cool art stuff even for me like
I've just been spending some time just
making some prototype floors and things
and then seeing what he's done with him
you know making pillars and columns
things that you would never imagine your
stuff being used it's like hey this
shape is inspiring this is awesome
and you worked on something recently too
in the engine we had a demo that was
played recently that you had worked on
Google yes yes I worked on that Google
demo as well as the Apple so the one of
the other things about detail levels and
stuff if you notice in some of these
hallways I tried to keep details
concentrated around doorways and above
you and the floors and the play areas
are nice and neat
there's just concentrated areas of
detail like the centerpiece here and
these these kind of door frames and
detail is very much in the periphery and
it shouldn't if if the hallway spaces
are are better than this and meant for
mesh work like this it shouldn't impede
gameplay and it should enhance
everything you should enhance visually
and and gameplay wise and all that
wonderful stuff so alright and we have a
bunch of questions and I actually don't
even have all of the questions that are
asked down here so we're not going to be
taking any questions from the stream
today but if you go back to the thread
Josh and Chris both are going to be
answering questions that didn't get
asked here today and before we go on I
also want to introduce a new member of
our team some of you may know him come
on over Pete
yeah you're gonna have to like you just
come on over here share yeah
we have Pete Napoli here he's a gameplay
programmer right
yeah I'm we're at the special I'm gonna
be doing some of the gameplay
programming along with metal key and Joe
Wilcox I did a lot of the multiplayer on
Gears and I'll be doing some of the
multiplayer kind of spectator mode stuff
for UT so I'm super excited I started on
Monday I can't wait to keep going and
we're very happy to have Pete with us
yes we are ok so let's get your
questions and like I said if I don't get
to it on here please check the forums
and I'll get back to them
great emerald asks what's your opinion
on the idea of making weapon models
configurable so it's something that
we've talked about a lot actually in the
past we talked about it with UT 3 and we
wanted to do it we actually talked about
doing configurable cliff a nice to talk
about doing configurable weapons back
before it was kind of the cool thing
that people were doing where you could
unlock upgrades so say you started with
base rocket launcher the fire nothing
but a rocket and then you could later
upgrade the ability to load multiple
rockets and then upgrade and the ability
to do grenades and you could kind of
custom design your own weapons and use
them how you wanted to use them or
adjust like oh I want a bigger shock
shock a radius bigger radius on my shot
combo but it does less damage so you can
kind of play with all these sliders and
do all this craziness and I think it's
still cool idea and it has a lot of
Merit that said visually I don't know
what we want to do in terms of
customization there's there's a lot
that's recognizable a lot about UT's
weapons and it's kind of kind of the
core of the game so we're a little
hesitant to miss with that I mean it's
gonna be a fine line with that stuff so
well it's hard because you T is all
about I see somebody coming with a
rocket launcher and I I know exactly
what they're capable of
when those variables start to move in in
weird directions where you don't know
what you're running into it can be
problematic especially for kind of
high-end competitive play the other flip
side to that is that if you look at kind
of the history of UT and you say like
like chaos UT which has had which was so
lost like so many weapons that did so
many crazy things like it doesn't even
matter anymore at that point it's just
about having fun and doing crazy stuff
so yeah we go either direction I said
really I might have done the voices of
proxy Minds at one time I don't really
like fun times fun times looks like yeah
another great question that I really
like is will opponents have that have
Armour picked up show differently from
those without armor like when you pick
up the shield belt you glow if you if
you pick up different pieces of farmers
there any way that the person who's
fighting you can tell that you have
armor on yeah I think we're gonna have
to have visual cues like that right
again it's something we're still
experimenting with and playing with one
of the cool things about the shield belt
is that you can see it
you can see it but you don't know how
much energy is left in it which is kind
of cool because the guy who has one and
the guy who has 100 both look
intimidating from a distance so you
can't really tell that said armor oh we
could do the same thing with it would be
a pretty big discussion in terms of
characters though if we were going to
show you know make one and an armor vest
that kids you know slot on top of every
character thigh pads a helmet whatever
all those things were but we could also
do something with okay a glowy helmet or
glowy whatever we represent misrepresent
bedazzle them yeah awesome the the
approach we have right now is kind of
the same we've done in the past where if
you hit someone with armor well we don't
really tell you other than you get that
kind of the hid effects what we've
talked about doing is instead of getting
blood you get spark effects until their
armor is gone and then you start getting
bud or something along those lines but
okay and great emeralds last question is
about shadow map quality he would like
to see that the JPEG artifact like get
avoided
is that something that they can do if
you're on a lower-end machine I just
think it's gonna be something I have to
play around with internal I'm not really
okay I don't really know a solution for
that right now so Mac d11 wants to know
he doesn't want to sound like he's being
critical but could we could we lead the
art style in a way that is not the other
extreme compared to ut3 so basically
this is what we were just talking about
he doesn't want it to be real white and
glowy and right as opposed to real dark
so right and I think one of the things
that we didn't do with this map that I
just showed was start to layer in decals
that some of the overlay decals like
grunge and and streaks and bird poop and
you know stuff I guess some of the stuff
that makes it makes it realistic and and
and a set gives it a real sense of place
and and anchors anchors the visuals so
that stuff's coming we're going to start
playing around with how grungy we should
be my guess is that it'll never be ut3
grunge but it'll be a little grunge here
than what we what we've seen just just
to add a little bit more of that that
punch yeah yeah totally
so it's not so sterile I think some
people might be reacting to seeing maps
and early development so you see the
very stark plain yes kind of the bsp
shells that we W we have so far like the
deck that's out there that has some
materials applied but there's there's
basically no geometry in it yeah and
that's that's just because we're in
early development that's not the right
art direction that where we're going for
that right now don't confuse the two
with regards to environment now that we
have such a powerful engine and lighting
effects do we expect problems to be able
to see the players at all no I don't
think so at all I think we're gonna have
to just experiment with that stuff in
the past we had problems seeing the
players because the players were as
detailed as the environments and they
were lit in the same way and stuff now
we will still have detailed characters
and detailed environments to an extent
but we have lots more tricks with
lighting and post-process and things
like that to allow those character and
and we're very much aware of a visual
clarity
and a clarity of experience for the
player so we will be very much
concentrating on that stuff and you know
working to make sure those characters
are really they really pop since that's
most of the experience in the game you
know you and I have talked a lot about
there's such a call right now for bright
skins from a lot of the really
competitive community and there's almost
kind of knee-jerk reaction in the other
direction from the non-competitive
players you don't want to be running
around with gluey gummy bears they
actually want to see the characters so
some people want to hide in the dark
spots and yeah like actually yes the
shadows know where they're intended so
what we're hoping for is that we can
find a good balance where characters are
visible whether they have a separate
post process chain like Josh and I were
talking about earlier or you know rim
shaders or different lighting rigs or
there's all these different things that
we can write there so that we don't have
just pure straight glowing characters
that we have something that still looks
good and feels right in the environment
but still maintains that level of visual
quality so it's a big challenge but I
think we'll get there okay that was by
quillian bye I think I forgot to say
that I always screw this one up
demon tears the men George my dear I
thought you said something else I'm just
gonna give up on these can animations
particularly advanced movement
animations like spinning rolling dodging
diving I'm not sure if he's asking as
the player or if you're looking at
another player but can they be made
distinct and apparent so like if
somebody's dodging can you tell that
they're dodging or I I was messing
around on a map with with Jo the other
day and he was dodging out of the way
and from his opinion from mine I could
really tell that he moves right you know
so as far as dodging goes yes but I'm
it's just something we're gonna have to
play around whether right animation is
one of the things I'd love to evolve
with this this game type this this type
of gameplay and it's hard because you're
again in a constant struggle of what
looks good versus what's responsive
right you need to turn on a dime you
need to you
360 and 180 and double jumping twin you
know Todd's jumping all that stuff and
that's not what a normal human does and
and so especially in that time frame
right yeah yeah especially in that time
frame so it's it's been a constant thing
how to make that stuff look good and
look natural but still give the
responsiveness without breaking the game
and I think it's well that's always been
one of the strengths of epic because I
think we have a just remarkably
incredible animation yeah and the stuff
that those guys can pull off yeah okay
Mecca Tash we've talked about this
before but look I knew the question was
coming going to come up again which
architectural themes can we expect to
see in the new UT for instance the
nekross which was kind of Middle Eastern
Asian with the Ronin the Egyptian well I
think we've already identified a couple
buckets and and days Polinsky put up a
list we've got you know there's a sci-fi
bucket there's a an industrial bucket
and there's a nolle kind of ruined
bucket and combinations of those that's
where we're going to start are there
room is there room for all this stuff
absolutely UT is kind of an
all-encompassing universe so I think if
someone wants to make an Egyptian map it
will get me so yeah it's it's it's a lot
of that stuff's gonna be up to you guys
right I mean it's what do you want what
do you want to do you know let's let's
do something fun and and if you make it
it's fun and then it's gonna be awesome
I think Dave put that graphic up in
forums as well it is yeah it shows all
the different buckets and then the ways
that they combine yes crazy stuff but
again that's just one subset of things
right right that's kind of where we
wanted to start we wanted to really
define what are the buckets of that make
UT UT and then move on from there and
then UT is defined by different buckets
for different people but for us the core
of UT was pretty much those buckets okay
and fly who is the newest
are you t prototyper a banner
congratulations fly for me oh he has a
lot of questions anything from me design
and visual clarity are immediately
linked to each other so should some
questions not fit in this dream topic
feel free to ignore them okay I will do
that okay so the first question we've
already answered a review are you
leaning towards lots of white and clean
we're going to be all over the place
yeah and first life.i which is currently
super hip what we're always super hip
yeah we're not gonna just go go one way
did you guys look at original maps and
unlit and lit mode to see the
differences that was done with the
lighting and textures yeah I mean I
posted that stuff to the forums right
and and there's some specific forums in
is it the environment art forms or I
think it's any environment art forms
right where I took all three games and I
posted lit and unlit versions with
screenshots comparing you know density
of detail and mesh work and and texture
and shader work and lighting and stuff
like that and it was really good to see
all three games side by side it was it
was like all three had deck and I chose
levels that were in all three games too
so deck was one of them and I had a shot
from 99 deck 2004 and ut3 deck and and
you could see the stark contrast between
ut3 and how far we swung into the dark
and dreary and and mucky stuff you know
which at the time I was felt felt like
it was okay you know but a lot of that
was lighting a lot of his post next door
to a lot of different and we were
learning again we were learning the tech
right and so it was new we were doing
gears and I was winning all kinds of
awards for visual quality and stuff and
so we know wow naturally we'll take it
and we'll do we'll do this you know and
and it wasn't a good fit in hindsight
but everybody there's everything yeah
and then the lighting now is amazing you
can make a map look completely different
just with lighting now yes yeah what do
you consider more important the original
themes or modern things so you were a
Nelly guy or
you more something like this now I like
them all I think it can all be fantastic
right I am a I am a I am a dark hardcore
guy and I like the dungeons and stuff
like that but I find beauty and and for
example the level I showed you know and
I just I like it all a good art is good
art right I mean it's it's all good I'm
not sure about this one but I'm gonna
ask it anyway so does anybody know what
why two ut2004 was a little bit more
brightly colored in comic than than
other games in the in the past that one
just went with a it was a very different
theme different it was kind of a
divergent storyline I went in a weird
direction it was very much kind of
sports theme and then they kind of went
almost over the top into a like WWE
wrestling it was so you 2003 was
actually meant to be unreal championship
it was meant to be a completely
different product on a different
platform for a different audience really
and at the very last minute de wouldn't
finish that while epic kind of took over
you to 2003 and kind of got that out the
door as a as a PC product and then
knowing that that wasn't quite the right
way to go we immediately follow that up
with ET 2004 which is kind of more what
our vision was for UT at the time but
that said it was also built on top of
each 2003 so it had a lot of the same
characters and look and feel but yeah it
was definitely a little bit more
whimsical a bit more cartoony and
differently over-the-top as opposed to
the gritty hardcore that's you and we
were a different studio back then I
think there was there was no art
direction on those products it was hey
let's get together and have a meeting
and everybody go back and do some cool
stuff and and we worked in conjunction
with the community and it it worked
miraculously but yeah I mean we're kind
of going back to that now - I mean it's
it's art directions very loose and we're
the community and we're kind of just
doing some cool stuff and it's got a
really good vibe I think the project we
need to get more contributions from the
environment art guys yeah Josh for sure
well slide slide does have a lot more
questions so and he had so many he may
actually made his own threads so one of
you guys will go back and or both will
go back and talk to sly and his thread
about those questions so we're gonna go
jump down to a Sulha and in regards to
character motto visual clarity and UT
through the carrot or the characters had
colored lights the LED lights on them
they thought that was a great solution
to bright skins and had a futuristic
sporty feel good is there any chance I
couldn't return and he posted a
screenshot of like Tron with the dark
skin yeah I know what he's talking about
I wasn't a fan of that stuff but we'll
see as you know the artists and art
directors in particularly you want that
purity of experience but you also want a
purity of visual right and and to a lot
of us the the glowy bits break that it's
a game ISM that kind of breaks some of
that stuff but the technology is further
along now and I think there's a way to
make loi bits look really good and
really sci-fi on some of the characters
so so we'll see I mean it's we're gonna
play around with stuff and see I just
didn't like the blue me crazy stuff you
know but if we can do it in a tron
tasteful type away I think that that
works right again going back to you 2003
it was glowy lights on the shoulders and
nowhere else yeah that was distracting
and weird so we got rid of him for a
2004 and then we introduced trim shaders
and so we've messed with a lot of
different ideas yep and one of things
that we were just I don't know if Matt
finished it or not but we were just
getting into the game recently was we
were going to experiment with the
ability to let players choose their own
color so it didn't have to be red didn't
have to be blue they can do whatever
they wanted and so that'll affect the
way the materials are built and how we
display that color and all these other
things so I'm sure you guys have a good
challenge on your in a way to make that
look awesome did you skip over Cerberus
his comment oh did you want it I thought
it was kind of a thing it kind of got
answered by what we showed it I think
yeah yeah we answer surprises questions
oh I'm just kidding Bryn is basically he
just wanted to see some examples of okay
I just didn't want to I didn't want to
overlook them I don't know what's going
on here okay let's see next page next
page Raptor Raptor wants to know if
we're leaning more towards weapon models
from UT 99 you teach 2004 UT 300 Chris
address I think for the look of the
weapons we're taking a look at what
makes each weapon iconic for example a
flat cannon what is you when you think
of a flat cannon what is it and I'm sure
there's a million different views on
that but we we are kind of narrowing
down those ideas what's your favorite
model my favorite model is the is it the
two that I think it's a 2004 model it's
not the 2013 3 model I think that one
looks it's just go ahead say it
it's odd it's just odd looking it looks
like a flower on the end or something
weird and I know it's supposed to be
among cool mining equipment that piece
thing but for me weapons should be
tapered and they that's your your way to
touch the world and it brings you into
the world when you're running around in
perspective and that thing just kind of
blossoms out like a cherry thread and
you just kind of take a pompom that
you're riding around with and it always
just kind of bothered me a little bit
the design of that one so I wouldn't I
would kind of change that I think the
ut3 enforcer needs to be a little
beefier it feels a little pewpew to me
we've had a lot of good submissions to
the unreal enforcer seemed a lot better
a lot chunkier and and so I don't know
we'll see I think we're gonna like I
said well look at all the iconic weapons
and figure out what's right are there
any that there were a few of the weapon
concepts that we've seen that we've
we've got a like - right yes I just yeah
the shock rifle was was one of the ones
that I thought was was pretty cool send
more and we'd like those are some ideas
on what you guys want and what you guys
think they should call halt mod no shoot
spunk on there yeah this is a this is a
long one this this is from
God was wrapped her I said that this is
from Bill bailius this isn't quite a
visual clarity question but more art
direction and design Chris mentioned
previously that he hoped to see multiple
skeletons in the game eventually does
that indicate there will be space for
multiple sizes of player models as well
or should character models be planned
around the general size of the demo
characters and Malcolm no I wanted to
see skeletons hanging on the walls
I just meant what I meant by that
comment I was thinking about the scar
for that comment and and having a a
character with the tail or a I'm totally
drawing a blank on the other the other
beastial race their role yeah the crawl
you know having different skeletons for
those type of things or even a not like
a badass nollie running around with
forearms or whatever they would
obviously need different skeletons and
so that's kind of what I'm into that
comment that's kind of what I was
talking about yeah from a design
perspective at least right now we want
all of our characters to be the same
size just for scale and movement all
those other things so yeah if you're
gonna make the giant character nobody's
gonna play the bad character they're
gonna be an easy target nice arcade more
hit points and then we started getting
into this class-based system it's a
completely different game doorways need
to change I mean there's a lot of
problems with level design that comes
with different scale characters and
stuff too so the holy it affects a whole
everything so what about one of my
favorite subjects character
customization have we thought at all
about that is that gonna be something
that we even look at I don't know I mean
I haven't we haven't thought about it
we're just worried about getting
characters in there and getting
character models that stuff so right now
so yeah did want to work on some type of
you know just being able to change
colors and stuff like it would be
fantastic to do I imagine if there's a
if there's a marketplace eventually for
this that it would be really cool to
have different sets of armor and stuff
for characters that would be great
it'll be great if you could blueprint
them into having this totally effects
game place I don't know what I'm talking
about but I'm having armor that has
special abilities special powers I don't
what but I mean even guys a limit on it
because I like the idea of people being
able to customize with you know their
own clan helmet their yeah oh yeah yeah
like you say or build instead of having
the worrying that build a whole
character I can just build boots and I
could put those in the marketplace and
I'll be coming baby's favorite boots and
also of 5,000 copies em whatever I don't
know but I like the idea of it we just
gotta figure out a way to work it into
whatever character system yeah okay
let's see the tie and some other
questions can you touch on how PPR
material system can be used to aid
visual clarity while maintaining a
detailed environment and how clear does
not specifically mean simple or plain
that's Josh yeah it just yeah it just
depends on how you want to build your
materials how you want things to look
basically our PBRs physically based
rendering so all of our materials kind
of react to light the way that they do
in the real world so everything has
specular highlights everything has a
metal nasaan a roughness and those are
kind of combined in tandem to get the
kind of look you want so I think Jordan
Walker did a pretty good blog post on
Unreal Engine 3 dock or Unreal Engine
comm about that yeah so they they should
definitely go take a look we have a
bunch of documentation on all that to
get everyone up to speed and we're also
playing around balancing normal map you
know high poly low poly processing
normal map assets versus medium poly
kind of modeling this the level I just
showed has a little bit of both and with
the the physically-based materials you
can have something that doesn't have
normal maps on it that has material
layers on it that has that separates out
rubber for example in chrome and and
more of a painted material all on the
same mesh without a normal map and it
looks it looks fantastic so that's
another way that you can kind of
experiment with that stuff and related
to that Josh how well does the material
system support fallbacks for lowering
so we have a note I wrote it now I
forgot it's called a yeah the quality
switch node and it basically you can
switch between like dx9 dx10 dx11
shader model 3 4 & 5 so if they have a
low-end machine they can just add the
node at the end of their material and
and he also he also has what's the
lowest target hardware we haven't
started talking about that yet so we're
not sure we're gonna try to make it run
as on many machines as possible of
course can character settings and design
concepts be pulled from previous it's
unreal university games for example if
they wanted to bring back John Dalton
from unreal 2 as a as a tournament
character or any of the characters from
you see to accept Raiden I don't know
why not maybe and with newly built
models and textures would this be
acceptable or discouraged I would say
you can do anything you want at any
point the only stickiness comes in there
is if you're going to try and sell it in
the marketplace right because you can't
tolerate we can't let you sell something
that's copyrighted by someone else
without their permission so but outside
of that if you just want to do it for
fun and get an in play with your friends
go to town - are there any recurring
characters that epic wants to build
in-house for sure which the community
should avoid another good question we
are working maybe on a character right
now that well I mean I would yeah we're
talking about getting we have Malcolm
who's coming in right now and we're
talking about the possibility of
including Lauren just so we have a
female actor as well but these aren't
new characters right and they're not and
they're temporary they're not into
permanent and they're just a rescan of
like ut3 characters yeah basically you
can do whichever character you'd like
right absolutely and we have no we
really know no claim to net - nothing at
this point I do want to create a new
weapon or a new level or a new character
please go for it by all means that's
exactly what we want and what we need I
mean we need i'm i'd love for character
models i would not hate it if someone
redid the soldier models from you throat
UT yes look at that banika back again
due to the lack of visual clarity in ut3
the community came up with bright skins
what do you think about brain scans
so we don't we talked about that already
yes we talked about that we would rather
that you got to use them yeah we want to
find a balance where everybody can play
and enjoy it visually and it looks
normal as opposed to bright skins but I
understand why people do that and so
ideally we'll find the balance that
makes everybody happy and going back to
what we talked about with user
experience are there any new plans for
the different colors for the teams like
I said earlier we just started this week
messing with the ability for you to
select whatever color you wanted that's
going to have a lot of design fallout
that we haven't dealt with yet and yet
in terms of you know how do we adjust
lighting in maps how do we adjust
character skins how to read just flag
color all these all these things you
know HUD and everything but all of that
is fixable it's just a technological
challenge that we haven't gotten around
to and what about first off first models
like you know yeah yeah yeah so you want
to always have the juggernaut for
everybody yeah so that's you know like
again it's a competitive play thing
where I don't care what you what
character you're using or what you're
using I want to just set it to a default
so that everybody looks the same so that
I'm not distracted whatever kind of
evens the playing field
visually in a lot of ways it may or may
not be an option okay jump buyer says
looking back at your title specifically
the UT and Gears of War development it's
obvious that some of the UT 2k for style
did flow into your final gears models
thematically are we still going to be
looking at the the characterized and
bloated models specifically on the armor
are we looking at something more
realistic yeah I think we're gonna aim
for something more realistic this time
around I think we're going to be bring
the proportions down a little bit and
yeah there's joint
yeah we I think I think we should bring
them back and then I think we're gonna
do that I think we're gonna environments
you know I talked about that earlier the
Tim Burton versus Chris Nolan Batman
kind of thing right
they were that Cirie's got characterized
as it went on and I think we you know we
went a little overboard sometimes with
that but with this UT what I'd love to
do is bring some of that stuff back and
there's been some fantastic concepts out
there of normal proportion UT characters
that look really good that I'm dying to
build or have somebody build you know
okay yeah
another Gears of War based question is
there any any color themes or are we
already talked about this
are we gonna be muting certain color
palettes no I think we'll do what the
level calls for right I mean if we've
got a space dungeon that'll be dungeon
II and you know we've got a high tech
facility it'll it'll look that way you
know it's gonna the color and the
palette will dictated by the
environments a very nice way of asking
for into saturated right having good
looking forward to somebody doing like a
hyper blast where you're flying through
space and you're seeing nebula yeah the
wonderful colors so I hope to see lots
of colors out there and jump higher also
says you're doing amazing work and he
appreciates it thanks and we'll be we've
introduced to any new species beyond
those from previous games so they're
gonna be anything more than scar and
then Ali and the crawl don't know right
now currently not in development if you
build it yeah dr. Dre isn't dr. Dre Dr
Dre is DDR REE I'd had that wrong last
week okay or I can pronounce it as sner
does visual clarity mean we won't get to
see bleeding age UE for graphic tech
bleeding edge off leading age no I think
I think we will see bleeding edge I
think we're well on our way actually
talking about
I am yeah absolutely and yeah so you
talked about some of these already with
the Batman stuff what are other
inspirations that you have for visual
clarity for visual clarity it's just you
know kind of what I showed you in that
in that in that initial concept map I
think it's it's keeping things clean at
the player level and spreading spreading
the love around doorways and in targeted
areas that still make it look
bleeding-edge and modern and and things
like that but don't get in the way a
player it's gonna be a fine balance
right so there's a lot more that goes
into being bleeding edge than just the
number of polygons all right the level
of detail you're just the lighting model
the shaders I read all of that stuff and
yes
this is super hardcore bleeding edge
even in you know fortnight which is very
very cartoony but if you look at from a
bleeding edge technology perspective a
lot of that stuff is super high-tech yep
and so whatever visual style we end up
with I had no doubt that it was it will
be bleeding it will be bleeding yes very
bloody yeah can you elaborate on where
exactly does the visual clarity vision
manifest is it post-processing textures
lighting all of the above totally above
the way that with the PBR stuff and
everything it's it's it all works
together so you've got to massage the
materials you know you start with a cool
model and you massage the materials into
it then you light it and then you do
some more massaging and it all has to
work together right because the the
materials play off the lighting so much
and the roughness of the material and
all that stuff do you want to talk more
about that or I mean it's only hits it
on the head right yeah I can point
people to there's a company called don't
nod do NT n OD and they did a visual
breakout of how materials look at
different points in ue4 so roughness
zero all the way to ten metalness how
they kind of play together she's posted
on the forum that'd be pretty valuable I
thought I'll do that today yeah because
it's it's an awesome article
and let's say I'll make fly fly remind
me of all the things that we're supposed
to post on the forum so we don't forget
anything today and will we still get to
see super high detailed shock beam being
formed with a new ue4 attack yeah now
with more shock yeah I think we're just
gonna ask one more question sure
and this is from threadlock I've always
loved Unreal Tournament for the amazing
environments and the vistas that make
you stuff and go wow do you think visual
clarity can be bought combined with
detailed environments in a way that
pushes the graphics to next gen levels
yeah absolutely I think you know one of
the things you didn't see with the map
that I showed off the the working
concept as it as it were is is a cool
vist or a cool background a cool sky box
that's something we haven't tackled yet
but we're going to and that's a great
place to add all that detail that we
don't necessarily put right right and it
also gives the map up sense of place
like where am i what I do you know that
that type of thing so yeah it's also
very important thing you mentioned this
is a living model living concept early
on said you didn't really say why like
you were telling me about how right what
I'd love to do after the artist yeah
what I'd love to do with this is is so
I've taken it to a certain point and now
how do we make it better
right what can i what can Josh do with
it when I hand it to him what can Rick
Cole or do what they want to hand it off
to him port mater some of those guys and
then maybe what can the community do
with it when I pass it out online right
that would be a really cool thing to do
as well take a visual prototype like
this we're talking about it you know
we'll take a visual prototype like right
now none of this stuff is in UT game
right I'm just kind of off on the side
doing it because it's so messy and
there's so much churn to the assets and
stuff but we're talking about getting it
in there and getting it out the
community and say hey you know here's
our here's our bar take it and push it
go go beyond you know make meshes for it
make better materials do better
atmosphere lighting whatever you can do
and you know it's all good it's at that
point it's it's you know many Minds
coming together to make something great
I think so
this is really I know they're gonna ask
it's really just just a starting point
well it would be a couple of weeks at
the earliest so maybe maybe three or
four weeks at the earliest so tricky
vein that was from for the threadlock
tricky vein would like to know that he
said he's heard the term unreal DNA
thrown around a few times by Poorna and
Wow I generally think I know what it
means I wonder if he could be defined or
pinned down to say a little bit more
succinctly to a particular group of
styles or aesthetic from any of the
unreal games when you say unreal DNA
which what are you thinking when you say
unreal DNA it's it there's a there's a
certain color and a certain quirkiness
to a lot of the unreal stuff I can't I
can't really quantify it in a word or in
the phrase it means something else do
everything right and and there's so many
varied environments and stuff but they
all have this overall kind of charm to
everything that when you see an unreal
screenshot you kind of know that that's
from unreal I'd like this new game when
you see a screenshot from this game to
be our new unreal right and and that
that is what it is and when I when I
talk about some of the original DNA I
talk about hey let's not take the shock
rifle and make it a crazy whip or
something you know let's not kill all
the original work that's that was done
let's build on top of that and enhance
it and bring it to life in in a in a
modern way that that our new technology
allows you know if we could have had
this technology back in unreal one day
is what would we have done with it right
you know that's really good so we have
one other person here in the wings you
want to come say hello no one he's not
allowed to intrude we have our the
community manager from fortnight
standing in the wigs everybody say hello
to KL KL Smith and and we ikl will be
next back next week we hope maybe we'll
have Pete on or
we're actually not sure what we're going
to talk about one thing I really wanted
to I'm really excited about we're all
excited about is we are going to have
another YouTube video we'll be posting
it tomorrow Jason Beasley took some
sugar shots from last week film last
week of us playing and it will be up
either tomorrow Friday not sure exactly
when but we'll be sure to let you know
when it's out there so look forward to
that will be the podcast you tube of
this video will be up tomorrow and make
sure you stop by the engine stream
tomorrow because they're going to be
going over more four-point-three stuff
there's lots of cool stuff and that's on
twitch.tv slash unreal engine and I
think that's it for us anybody else have
anything nope that's it thank you thank
you guys thanks everybody behind the
scenes including Shelley back there and
Joe Wilson and we'll see you guys soon
thank you